foreign
welcome back to the best of the Ramsay
show I'm George Campbell co-host of the
Ramsey Show and in this episode we're
talking about work we all know money
comes from work and we take a ton of
career calls on the show some people
just don't want to work others are
bitter about their co-workers their
bosses or they feel guilty looking for
another job lots of drama check it out
Tyler is in Denver hi Tyler how are you
hey can you hear me okay absolutely
what's up great
um hi I'm a huge fan of your show I've
watched almost all your clips on YouTube
uh I'm really excited to talk to you
right now
um got a bit of a career question for
you
um my name is my name is Tyler I
graduated from college in 2019 in
engineering school
um I'm 24. I uh I work for an
engineering company make about a little
under 90 a year and um
you say this oh thank you a lot of times
I hear you say this quote on the on on
YouTube
um you know it's bad to have a mentality
of oh oh God it's Monday thank God it's
Friday kind of thing
um and I'm just kind of wanted to
elaborate on that a little bit um I
would say I'm kind of in that boat
um I really enjoy where I work you know
I work with good people I think the
stuff I do is is Technical and
interesting
but you know obviously if I had the
choice I obviously wouldn't work in nine
to five at a desk all day um so I'm just
wondering you know is that a bad
mentality to have how can I get out of
that or or what can I do about these
feelings
well let's just play this out you're 24
you've got an engineering degree the
work interests you but you gave us a big
clue I don't want to sit at a desk all
day that's not wrong to feel that way
but let's look at what the future what
what you want the future to be so let's
fast forward 34 44 what kind of work
would you want to be doing at this very
moment what would you say
yeah I mean I I love what I do
um you know I love I love Tech and I
love the engineering and I'm a computer
programmer essentially but um you know
so I move up in those ranks you know uh
start taking on Project leads and and
stuff similar to that but um but like I
said you know it's still a nine to five
thing
um I think I'm conflicted more you know
the idea of like well I'd rather be
doing this or that you know I'd rather
be outside I'd rather be you know with
friends and stuff like that and I'm not
saying obviously I don't like my job
because I do I I do so you're all over
the place so I want you to say it just
like you just don't want to go to work
yeah because outside and be with outside
with my friends that's great but that's
not work what do you want to do I mean
you started to give us a clue there you
up the ladder you're 24 first of all so
you need to relax you're in that entry
position uh and you're making almost
ninety thousand dollars a year so you're
in you're on the ladder so what does the
ladder look like what do you want to be
doing at 34 44 you want to work for
yourself how have your own tech company
what is it I know you've allowed
yourself to think about it say it what
is it
sure
um I mean I've never even really
considered the possibility of starting
something where I work for myself I just
kind of am under this assumption that
I'll be in some some corporate structure
okay forget assumption what are you what
do you wonder about when it's just you
what does the 45 year old you doing
professionally what have you allowed
yourself to imagine say it now let's
assuming you're working at something
yeah and playing with friends it's like
badminton in the backyard
yeah exactly no I I you know I obviously
I enjoy having a stable and steady
income
um so that I don't want to change
obviously Tyler
um you know what is the dream what I
want to do say it
say it I know you've thought it I've
done this enough tell me what you dream
about
what I dream about I mean I dream about
I thought I'd be panicking here no no
okay so here's something just moving up
in that moving up all right so moving up
tell me what moving up looks like what
are you forget about job title forget
about how much money you're making
forget about how you get there you're
letting your brain run I want your heart
to answer this question you love the
work of engineering you love that
creative technical aspect of what you do
is that true or false
true okay then so if you want to keep
doing that kind of work and moving up
the ladder you need to begin at 24 to go
what does that ladder look like way up
top start looking at that stop focusing
on well I'm out of dusk eight hours a
day well you're 24 man and paying dues
for you is really good right now I mean
you're making almost ninety thousand
dollars a year you're overthinking this
start to talk to Engineers who have been
at this for 10 years 15 years 20 years
what's the kind of work you would love
to do and if you want to retire at 40
great there's nothing wrong with that
man are you supervising engineer
products in the field in the field which
gets you out of the office
in the future uh no I I work for a
website company solving indoors most of
the time no I'm saying you might not be
working with the same company dude yeah
yes got it got it
if you're doing injury what kind of
engineer are you
I'm a computer engineer a computer
engineer okay all right I had I had you
engineering buildings for a minute I'm
sorry okay um
okay so you know you've just got to
decide I don't know of a situation I
can't think of a situation but I I'm not
an expert on your field uh I've got
about 300 of you working here but none
of them work outside
they all work in the building
um and so we don't have any computers
out in the amphitheater or the park next
door or around the fire pit or the
various places I mean I actually have
Wi-Fi out there you can go out there and
sit but um yeah but
um a nice day but the vast majority of
them work inside the building
so um yeah I think probably what I would
leave you with is this
um a
there's nothing wrong with paying your
dues for a few years and sitting there
and while you're making 90 grand pay
introduced to Ken's point is not bad uh
B and and so just plan on that b it does
not just because you do that for two the
next two years does not mean you have to
be doing that for two decades
you get to choose I'll tell you one
thing that I know one thousand percent
chance over the scope of my career I'm
one thousand percent chance your world
is going to change
computers are going to change
I mean when I when I was your agent
starting there weren't computers
the personal computer was not very
personal
and so I mean back when the dinosaurs
roamed the Earth it's hard to imagine
that but uh feels like 20 minutes ago
and then I've watched the computer
evolve into these tiny little things in
our hands which will do more than a
whole building full of them would do
just a few decades ago so fast forward
your thing a few decades uh you may be
doing stuff from sitting outside working
on Holograms I don't know something's
going to be different yeah and so and
and we're not picking on Tyler a lot of
people get in the situation this is what
we do every day on the king Coleman show
people get a little bit locked up and so
what we're pressing for is this allow
yourself to look out and say what's the
kind of work that I think would fire my
soul up and at 24 you might not know
that's the reality he's really young
today you might my point is with
technology curve today you might not see
how you're quote working outside unquote
uh doing your job but two years from now
it might be going everybody's doing that
and here's what they're doing that's
exactly I don't have any idea what going
to happen but so your the point is you
are not locked into this for 40 years
yeah there's no chance you can't do what
you're doing for 40 years it won't exist
right it won't even exist five years
from now that's right so start problem
solving in your head as an engineer as a
computer technology he really enjoys the
work there are Clues there so if you
want to work outside allow your mind to
wander a little bit and then go do some
research here's what I mean what are
some problems you want to solve that are
more outdoor in nature maybe one day
you've got your own company uh that is
anywhere you're in the truck and you're
moving around you're going from site to
site who knows but you've got to start
to look into that and you don't
overthink the fact that well I'm in this
indoor job right now then I get it he's
young but you've got to allow yourself
to explore some things and listen to
those Clues if you like being outdoors a
lot all right then well then how are you
solving the type of problems you like to
solve and how do you take that creative
solving and that technical solving
ability and go okay how could I do it
out here in this world and again not to
pick on him but it is a normal
thing in today's world
to go from high school to college
and your first job is you go to work
every day and you work all day yeah
and that's a new emotional experience
that's exactly right because you've not
done that Brent's with us in Boise Idaho
hey Brent what's up
hey y'all thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help questions for Ken
um Phil I just started um a new job a
month or two ago
um and I accepted
on my salary and I was happy enough with
it
um and then I found out about my
co-workers
are making about 50 more than I do like
45 what do you make um and I was
wondering
I'm making 22 an hour
doing what
uh medical lab scientist and they're
making 33 an hour
uh yeah 32.
are they measurably more experienced
than you
uh no
how did you come about this for all
dealing how did you get this information
I'm from them
there's two of us that work on this
particular two others in the me that
we're working on this one we're dealing
with Kobe
well I gotta lean I I got to tell you I
I gotta lean a little bit on Dave I got
some thoughts but Dave is a lot no no
but you've got a unique perspective on
how many people you've hired and fired
in culture development but I so so this
is really challenging okay because this
is all psychology and you're human and
so you've gotta you're gonna have to
Rise Above This is the straightforward
answer uh because if you don't this is
going to eat you alive and I don't think
you'll last very long uh this is the the
natural comparison
uh in comparison is a cancer the only
person I try to compare myself to is the
me of yesterday and and that's hard but
that's what you got to do
um because if if you're saying things
are equal and it's an equal playing
field they don't have any more
experience than you they don't have any
additional uh uh excuse me
certifications or all that stuff uh this
is a really nasty situation to find out
about I got to tell you I'm slight bit
cynical maybe suspect that you got the
information from them I'm not saying
they lied to you but the whole thing
just stinks and if you want to be there
here's the last piece if you want to be
there in the sense that it's the latter
you need to be on
for your career and where you eventually
want to get to and you got to be on this
rung to get to the next rung then you're
going to have to really suck it up and
be the better man here and and stay out
of this kind of stuff and earn the next
rung if you can't handle that then
you're eventually probably going to
self-select and have to get out of there
and I'm sorry that it's happened to you
because it's a real devastating
psychological blow it's a really good
question you brought to the Forefront
here and the interesting thing about it
is your tone when you're asking the
question is not whiny you're just like
it's it's like a curiosity to you which
is a positive thing so there's not a
you're not angry or bitter or something
like that you're just like this doesn't
make sense it's like a scientist right I
mean it's there's a riddle here and so
uh I'm gonna join you in the riddle why
would you if you were to guess
why the discrepancy in Pay What would
you guess
um
because they are I mean it's a business
or hospital and they're just trying to
get as little
um or pays little I came from a you
don't think it's an oversight
um
you know there you don't think they saw
something different in your
qualifications than the other guy you
don't think there's a logical
explanation other than just sheer they
didn't want to pay as much and they
thought they could get away with it and
they did
and they did I didn't come in I thought
the job was a technician job not a
technologist job
um and so when they gave me my pay I was
like well this is really exciting yes
I'll take this because it's like four
bucks more than I thought it was going
to be
um and then I found out what the job
really entailed I
I am a biochemist not a medical lab
scientist I see um yeah I've been
learning to play golf and I figured out
the secret to happiness is low
expectations
um yeah so yeah you had low expectations
and then you got a four dollars more and
you thought this is wonderful and then
you found out your ten dollars under and
it's all about expectations what Ken
said it's a psychological problem so
what is the environment like uh what's
the environment like between you and
your supervisor or your hiring the
person that did the hiring with you is
this a an open conversational good
people or is it very chain of command
real shut your mouth get your work done
I mean what is it authoritative or I
is that is a great question
um the only time I've met my supervisor
is the day I was interviewed she went on
leave right after that and then has
since come back from leave and then
never stepped in and I'm a night shift
and so I haven't
uh she's gone before I come in yeah
well I
um
what I have figured out is that there's
going to be a difficult conversation
it is going to be in your head
and your head's going to explode or
eventually or you're going to have a
difficult conversation and the the trick
is how to sit down with her and have a
difficult conversation and what uh one
of the things we teach leaders to do and
uh you're leading up in this situation
is to just if if if there's an elephant
in the room go hey there's an elephant
over there don't act like he's not there
and so let's just call out a couple
things that we know here okay number one
when I interviewed for this job I first
thought it was this and then I found out
it was that and I was four dollars more
than I thought and so I was really happy
and I'm grateful and by the way I am
grateful for the job and I haven't got
gotten to talk to you a lot because
you've been out on leave and of course
I'm night shift but I'm swinging by this
afternoon to have a five minute meeting
with you just and I want you to hear
nothing but gratitude from me
um but I got to talking to the other
guys in the lab and I found out that I'm
the only guy with the exact same
qualifications that makes 22 and they
all make 32. and what I want to ask you
is what can I do
to make myself worth 32 to you guys
because I'd like to measure up and
apparently I've not done that yet
and that pretty well
exposes the crap
without it you're going you people rip
me off you know that's the other way to
approach it in which case you just get
fired Brett really quick I want to jump
and ask this question are you able to do
the market research and be able to show
that there's a range of income and that
the work you're actually doing
uh does pay higher can you is that is
that something you can find the evidence
for and show that in the marketplace
um there is they are actually above
average what the other two are making
yeah well what I would do I would just
say all of this yeah I'm just saying
number one I'm happy at 22. I'm not
coming in here to gripe about them
making more and number two I know that
the Payette Brown here is above average
in general but what I'm trying to do is
figure out how I can be more valuable to
this place so that I can be worth it and
you put me in for a 32 instead of a 22
but I I want to earn it and I want you
to tell me how I can be the best person
I need to be to do that and I don't want
you to hear anything from me but
gratitude listen if if your boss gets
twisted up about that your boss is an
idiot yeah there's your sign
it's not a long-term stay yeah the one
thing they go shut up and get in your
corner you accepted the job right then
uh then start looking for another
position but but I don't think they will
I um I think you're bringing it up and
what you're doing is you're exposing the
fact that all of these facts are here oh
by the way you can also say I accepted
the job at 22. so I did this deal and
I'm so I can't come in and gripe about
the deal I'm not here to gripe about the
deal I took the job and uh and so you
know the fact that somebody else makes
more does not make me unhappy but what I
do want to do is I want to figure out a
track that I can get on to be of value
to this place to where I can join them
in that kind of an income because that
would make me feel really fulfilled and
I would know that I did a good job for
you guys Robin is with us Robin is in
Lexington Kentucky hi Robin welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi uh thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so I'm in a straight situation my
husband and I we just recently started
the baby steps which I want to say thank
you for because your program finally
convinced him that it was stupid to be
safe to be saving for retirement while
we still have debt
um and which means I won
um so very excited to be paying that all
that off good um but um we I am a
research and analyst for
um an agency in the intelligence
Community which makes me a government
contractor so this vaccine requirements
kind of coming down the pike for me and
I'm not one of the people that's willing
to get it
and I was wondering what your suggestion
would be about pausing paying on our
student loans and trying to like kind of
save up some money for my impending
unemployment if this were to continue
forward
well how far are we talking in the
future you think this is a month two
months six weeks what are you hearing
um so the emails that we've gotten are
early December and of course that that's
all subjective right so I mean I haven't
seen the actual executive order come out
yet I haven't you know there's a the
lawsuits aren't done yet I mean there's
there's a million things that could
happen but I'm I'm a planner and
if I get fired from this job because for
this reason I don't have skills to get
paid the same level outside of
government work how do you know I'm not
saying you're wrong but I want you to
answer that how do you know that as a
research analyst and the kind of work
you do that that's not transferable
outside
well I'm supposed typically a language
enabled research analyst Chinese
language for future threats Technologies
so it's not there's not a huge Market
out there for that and now I could apply
my language and that ability to other
things but they wouldn't pay on the same
I totally understand but let me also
share with you that yes that's a super
super specific position but the fact of
the matter is Chinese language and that
that linguistic skill aside you're
really good at research you're really
good at analyzing things true or false
true well I I'm just going to challenge
you that uh what do you make now
um I'm making 80 000 and this is my
basically an entry level
um I'm I'm in line for you know do this
for a year and they bump you up about 20
grand so yeah have you done any research
out in the marketplace to see what's out
there near 80 grand doing that type of
work forget the specific nature I mean I
don't know about research I did look for
a job for eight months when we got
kicked out of China to come back here
because of covet in the first place
um and I was unsuccessful I finally
found a job in local government doing
what I I really enjoyed it
um but it paid about half of what I'm
making now
um so I I don't know about research but
I know that it's really really hard to
get a job with Chinese language research
analysts and not a ton of
um
of experience in the in the field sure
well again I'm gonna I'm Really Gonna
challenge you you are a researcher by
nature and I think you've got to take
this really serious I think just to
assume well I'm gonna have to this is
all I'm gonna have to pause my baby
steps to try to weather this as opposed
to what can I do that's proactive uh I
think that's what you've got to be doing
right now and I think you have so much
experience and so much skill that's
transferable you've got to be looking
into what corporate jobs uh that are are
good fit for me and if I'm making 70 but
I think just to assume that you can't
make 80. I think that's uh you got some
more work to do on that I really would
challenge you to do some homework
okay and I
while you're doing that I have to agree
with your initial idea too I'm gonna
stop the baby steps and pile up cash
because I'm gonna until you land
something else you know I think there's
a real high heavy probability you're
going to be done there if you're
unwilling to be vaccinated and so
um I think the president has made it
pretty obvious what his intent is on
that and the only question is whether he
is has the power to pull it off or not
before we get slimmed with 5 000 or 50
000 on you know constitutional
challenging uh lawsuits which is what's
going to happen but the question is is
that going to save your job I don't I
don't know and I would be pretty
pessimistic about that in this
environment so yeah I'm gonna stop and
pile up cash but I'm also going to start
re-analyzing how your skills fit into
the marketplace at Ken's suggestion and
see if you can't land something
that's there maybe even some some
independent things that aren't
government contracts but maybe you're
just Contracting out uh to defense
contractors and so forth but even those
I think the uh
the president's going to try to anything
that touches the federal government is
going to try to hit it and uh so it's
it's going to be a it's going to be a
lot of
arguing going on before things are
decided it's not as easy as the stroke
of a pin
um in a democracy so right or wrong
that's going to be your facts so um yeah
I'm going to pile up cash for a while
here until until I I feel like I've got
a greater than 50 percent chance of
staying
um and and then once you've got that
then you know you can calm down a little
bit Jenny starts off this hour in
Charlotte North Carolina hi Jenny how
are you
hi gentlemen I'm honored to speak with
you both thanks so much for taking my
call our pleasure how can we help
well I want to tell you Dave your new
website is fantastic so good job whoever
you hired it's amazing well thank you
our in-house team did that and I will
give them a give them a high five from
you thank you
great my question
um I've been a stay-at-home mom for
almost five years now my husband and I
have a two-year-old and a five-year-old
almost five-year-old and my husband is a
controller down here and he makes about
170 and he he I would call him a very
very loyal
person employee he has great integrity
he's just amazing and he um his job as a
controller down here his his company
keeps acquiring other companies and when
he took the job five years ago they've
warned him hey the books are a mess
um you know you're going to stumble into
a lot of problems and this is just what
keeps happening with this company and as
they keep acquiring more companies
they're buying companies that have the
books that are a mess I'm not an
accountant so I don't know anything
about that however he just recently
recently received 140 000 bonus it was
two weeks ago and we have been looking
at already moving to different states
he's been looking at other jobs and now
it's kind of he's in the the debacle of
well I just received this huge bonus am
I gonna look like you know not loyal
just like a you know a not great
employee not a great person if I take
this bonus and leave or shall he wait it
out a little bit longer would just love
your opinion from both you gentlemen and
what you think what a fabulous question
yeah that's great
so you've hired and fired more people
than I have I'm thinking through my
thoughts on that what do you think Dave
I really like your husband
um loyalty is
um
a type of Integrity a piece of Integrity
that is
uh uh a vast Wasteland land in our
culture it doesn't exist it doesn't
exist so um I I really appreciate him
being what I would call Old School in
that regard and
um uh but I do not think that the uh I I
think he's been paid and bonused for
work that he has done not work that he's
going to do
and and so I don't think he's doing
anything morally wrong or even violating
loyalty
um
I'm trying to reverse the shoes for a
second and say gosh if I was his leader
and we just gave him 140 000 bonus on
170 000 income let's do a fun thought
experience
I would appreciate not getting noticed
two weeks later uh that would feel a
little icky uh if the roles were
reversed right uh but also I don't
expect someone
uh to uh to stay here when uh when it's
their time to go
um you can you know we tell people all
the time you cannot work here and go to
heaven
and so um you know it's you it's this is
not uh it's not the only place to work
it's a great place to work but it's not
the only place to work and so sometimes
people's season their they they run
through their uh the energy that they
had for the cause uh I'm not leaving but
other people have and so I've you know
come to accept that so I I would think
some amount of a little bit of time I
mean he wasn't you weren't going to give
notice next week anyway you still
haven't found a job you don't know where
you're going but if you leave in the
next six months I don't think you've
done anything wrong
six minutes you didn't do anything wrong
but it just feels icky you know what I'm
saying it's not cool yeah
huh yeah John what are you thinking yeah
I'm really wrestling with this one Dave
because I'm trying to think if I gave
someone 140 000 dollars
this is me being transparent I think in
some way I would be attempting to
pay them for work done and buy their
continued loyalty and I think that's a
bad motivator I mean um we've you know
and the same thing can just be saying if
I pay somebody a huge income right
but I don't want someone especially
someone I'm paying a huge income to
right to be here and not be happy yeah
be miserable their time is done
um you know it's bad enough if you're
paying somebody a little bit of income
in there that way but it's really bad if
you're paying them a lot of money and
their heart has left so he always tells
people you know when your heart leaves
the building take your butt with it yeah
hey Jenny so is he just tired of the
constant Acquisitions is he is he is it
a toxic work culture where people are
not cool to him and then they just will
throw money at him what's the thing no
it's nothing like that the people the
people that he works for the bosses are
my age they're 35 years old and they've
just built up this amazing company and
they're they're amazing people there's
no toxicity at all it's just every
company they acquire they're getting it
on a deal and so here you go CPA
controller just work with these messed
up accounting books but I don't know
like I said I don't know anything about
accounting and it just keeps piling and
piling but
you know here's a suggestion and yeah
here's a suggestion you know number one
uh what controllers are supposed to do
is control that's why we call them that
and so they're supposed to clean up
messed up books
if he goes to another company uh I mean
there are very few companies that do a
wonderful job with accounting uh most of
them do an okay job or a really bad job
uh and depending on the size of the
company the sophistication of the
company and so forth but
um you know we have Stellar accounting
issue was
but but I think I think he might ask for
some help I think he might be
overwhelmed yeah that's that's my
thoughts two little other pieces they've
hired a couple people to work under them
to work under him but then he end up
training all the people which is great
though because he trains them the way
that you know uh he likes
him training them
yeah right so he loves that but then
also he's not in charge of any decisions
too so I think and five he said five
years I'm putting in the work and we can
wait longer it was just kind of a bummer
because I mean you know what I think I
think that's the bonus and what is he
looking for in the new job there you go
that's different
and I would go in and ask for that here
because I think he's got a pretty good
gig yeah because what the big and I'm
basing that the big thing you said is
these are good guys
oh they're awesome yeah and if you go in
and go listen I'm frustrated by this and
this and in order for me to feel long
think longer term about this whole thing
I need to I need some help with you
adjusting those things Kyle is in Grand
Rapids Michigan hey Kyle how are you
hey Dave thanks for taking my call I
appreciate everything you guys do and
the opportunity to discuss my situation
sure what's up
so I just get into it I'm married with
three young children I'm in debt I hate
my job I'm having a problem with
drinking and I'm just feeling uninspired
broken and exhausted I've been working
with that but I have a ways to go and I
can't seem to get out of my own way when
it comes to figuring out my career and
getting my health together if you guys
need a little bit more backstory I can
give it to you but basically I would
just like some advice on how to proceed
because I've been struggling emotionally
since before my kids were born and I'm
still not happy with where I am which I
feel bad saying but but that's where I'm
at sure I want you to be as just brief
but very descriptive on you keep getting
in your own way as it relates to
figuring out what you want to do with
your career what does that mean
so I feel like I just keep coming and
hitting these mental roadblocks so I'll
I'll sober up and stay focused for a
week two weeks at a time and then
something will happen that'll trigger me
emotionally to want to drink or to do
something that's not related to the
career I want to have and a lot of times
I don't know if it's circumstantial or
if I'm getting in my own way right and I
heard of Hearts I feel like I can fix it
and that I'm just kidding
in my own way but at the same time I'm
in the grind of I'm in the grind of
early Parenthood and I'm dealing with a
lot of pressure from the career I
currently have and I'm the breadwinner I
get you most of our annual income comes
from my job so I feel like most of my
focus has to go there sure all right
family and it's getting in the way of
who I am sure so Kyle so I'm here lots
of things so the emotional stuff you
need to get some professional help on
that I'll talk about that in just a
moment but
you've had some ideas based on what I'm
hearing you have some ideas you may have
one clear idea that if I could snap my
fingers and put you in it on Monday
morning knowing you couldn't fail I got
a sense that you have an idea or two am
I right or am I wrong on what you would
do yeah you're right what is it no more
and listen here's what I want you to do
for the next for the next couple seconds
I don't want you to think
don't think don't qualify I want you to
answer my questions agreed
agreed here we go what is it tell me
what it is what would you do tomorrow if
you knew you couldn't fail
I'm I'm apprehensive saying it because
it seems but honestly I'd like to get
into game development game development
now you did what I told you not to do
but that's okay because we got the
answer you want to be a developer for
video games yes or no
yes okay do you have the Baseline
technical talent that if you were
trained properly that you know that you
could develop effectively game
technology yes or no
I would need additional training I don't
think so so the answer is yes you have
the core Talent if you were trained and
educated you could do it do you believe
that
if I was trained yes all right so hey
you gotta say for one second Kyle I want
you to throw off all this self-doubt
that's hanging on you like a giant
winter coat
throw it off
you can't even answer a question about
yourself because of the doubt and I know
there's a lot going on and I get that
but brother I just want you to get real
for a moment no wait a second do I have
the technical Talent now let me ask you
this why I want you to give me a short
answer why would you want to develop for
video games what's the why behind that
because I like creating experiences
there you go always had a knack for tech
technical stuff and always had a knack
or always had an interest in experiences
yes
yes okay and you're and you're a gamer
that's right so here's the deal you
think because you're a dad of three
small kids you guys have got some debt
and you're dealing with some emotional
stuff which is driving you to drink
you're thinking I'll never get there is
that about right
yeah I mean but that's not true but
that's not true so let me let me let me
challenge you all right you need to
understand that there is a path so you
know what you want to do if you if you
could just make it happen you know what
you want to do so you're in that get
clear stage now it's all about getting
qualified so you have to actually do the
homework and not get stuck in the bottle
and doubt and insecurity and fear about
what it's going to look like go what
would it take what has to be true for me
to be qualified to actually apply for
jobs like that and someone hire me is it
starting out in another development role
and getting development experience
somewhere else and then crossing over
the video game industry there's lots of
different paths brother I'm telling you
one thing I want you to do is call
Bethel Tech
betheltech.net they're a partner of the
Ken Coleman show and they take adults
from zero technology experience zero to
working in the technology industry in
nine months less than 15 grand you're
not there yet you got to get your debt
paid off Dave Ramsey Ramsey solution we
can help you with that but you got to
believe that you can get there and then
I think you got to get healthy Dave I
think he's got to get healthy and he's
got to get on the debt elimination plan
and we put the dream on hold doesn't
mean it's gone doesn't mean we never get
there but you've got to get out of debt
and you've got to get healthy
emotionally to where you believe that
you do have what it takes and that you
have a unique contribution so that
you're not leaning towards the bottle
so are you guys involved in are you guys
involved in church at all
no not
how old are you
I'm 34. okay
all right when I was a young dad
um I wasn't either and I wandered in the
back door one it changed my whole life
because I got men and women in my life
that would walk beside me as I changed
some of the habits I needed to change to
be successful
and I like that idea of it and I I'd
have I have asked my wife about that
because we're yearning for that sense of
community and I feel like just that just
the overall message and sense of
community whether we're religious or not
would be helpful exactly we almost went
to church for that reason alone that's
okay that doesn't I mean that won't make
anybody mad even the people at the
church just go over there and make some
friends with good people
and good people to walk beside you and
once they're good enough friends to
reach over and pop you on the back of
the head if you're drinking too much
that's a really good friend
right yeah
you need a butt you needed some buddies
in your life man you need a band of
brothers that love you enough to knock a
knot on your Noggin
I agree with that and you can pick it up
there and you wouldn't hurt to step into
a 12-step program wouldn't hurt to sit
down with a a good counselor and uh
because you know what amounts to is
you're stuck and the way you get unstuck
you get new information and new
inspiration
yes sir and um and and that helps you
then build a vision for your life that
Ken was laying out for you that you can
believe in and when you believe in that
Vision then you can run through walls to
get there
hey if you enjoyed this episode click
here to watch the next one featuring
calls all about building and handling
wealth